[MUSIC PLAYING]
MATT BLUMBERG: My
name is Matt Blumberg.
I'm a Product Manager
on the Chrome Team.
And today I'm going to
talk about Chrome browser
in the enterprise.
Leave some time
at the end for Q&A
and also note that we have a
space, the Android and Chrome
sandbox and Mosconi
on the third floor.
So please stop by there
tomorrow if you have time.
So this is just a quick
overview of the agenda.
Again really just going to
cover a lot of the features
for Chrome in the enterprise.
And again happy to take
questions at the end.
So first we're going
to cover why would
your company want
to switch to Chrome?
What are some of the
benefits of using
Chrome in your enterprise?
By show of hands who's using
Chrome today at the office?
OK, so mission accomplished.
So starting off with
our key pillars,
every feature that we design
has these key pillars in mind.
So when we start with speed we
know speed, is very important,
and it's every second
counts when you're
trying to complete a task.
And we want Chrome to be as
responsive and conservative
with system resources
as possible.
From a simplicity perspective,
we want to delight our users
and optimize for predictability
with concise actions
and solutions.
And we know security is one
of the most critical areas
for enterprises.
And we want to be as transparent
regarding security and privacy
by ensuring users are informed
in non-technical terms.
I'm sure you've seen Aw Snap
or green padlocks, red lines
if the certificates aren't
valid on the Omnibox.
And we safeguard
our users by letting
them know that they're
protected as well as warn them
before reaching malicious sites.
And from a manageability
perspective,
we want to give
IT Administrators
every bit of control over their
end users experience possible.
So in the old days, you'd have
a Native App for opening PDFs
and another one for
spreadsheets, another one
for documents and so on.
But we really see the
web browser as a window
into all of your enterprise
applications in the future.
Software upgrades can be
deployed with a simple refresh
of the web page.
Chrome offers a better
experience for users,
complete manageability for IT
and the latest web technology
for developers to
build on top of.
So I'm sure many of
you checked your phone
in the morning, maybe
one on your laptop
and got some things done before
coming to the conference.
Maybe throughout a normal
day in between meetings
you go to your desk and
have a desktop PC there.
In the evening maybe you check
some emails on a computer
at home or on a tablet.
The browser becomes
the universal platform
across all of these devices.
And what they have in common
is that they're all connected.
The platforms may differ but
why shouldn't your experience
be seamless across
every device you use.
By signing into Chrome
services, like Chrome Sync
will allow users to
easily and quickly pick
up right where they left off.
So today every application
must run on every device.
Your users expect
that, and they expect
it to be seamless across
corporate issued and often
times personal devices.
The fact is that today's
information workers,
on average use 10 web
apps across three devices
to do his or her job.
Today's best business
applications,
like Salesforce and G Suite,
Work Day and many others
are all web based.
Even traditional enterprise
vendors, like SAP,
are now building
their new applications
for the web based on HTML 5 and
they work very well in Chrome.
To empower your employees with
today's best business tools
companies have to
use the browser that
is the best support,
with the latest web
standards like HTML 5.
We're also seeing a big uptake
in enterprise development
of progressive web apps.
You may have heard more
about this in other sessions
at the conference.
But all of the
features that you have
with Native Apps such
as push notifications,
offline functionality,
adding icons
to home screens
on mobile devices,
launching in full-screen
mode, access to the clipboard,
all of these things are possible
and progressive web apps,
and they can run across any
device mobile or desktop.
So when we launched Chrome
in September of 2008,
the world said, who needs
another web browser.
And if we jump
forward to today, we
have more than 2 billion
users across Chrome desktop
and mobile.
We are very close--
I believe today or tomorrow
launching Chrome 57.
And we are seeing HTML 5, and
progressive web app adoption
continue to gain traction
in the enterprise.
Specifically, in the
past couple of years,
Chrome has seen hyper growth
in the enterprise space.
We are making large investments
on our enterprise engineering
resources as well as working
closely with our largest
enterprise partners who
are building SAS solutions
and aligning priorities
to ensure those solutions
work very well.
And we're building the right
features for the future
for enterprise customers.
It's just an overview here
of security and privacy.
So we obviously take
security very seriously.
And technologies like
Safe Browsing, Sandboxing
and our ability to
quickly deploy updates
are what makes Chrome the
most secure browser available.
Activant, which is
now known as Octave
wrote an extensive report
comparing Chrome browser
security to other browsers in
the industry several years ago.
And it goes into a lot of depth
on what the differentiators are
from a Chrome
security perspective.
So feel free to
review that report.
We also have updated
content on our website
regarding Chrome
security features.
And we will be refreshing the
security report in the coming
months so that you can
watch out for that as well.
So as I mentioned, security
is one of our key pillars.
And Chrome was designed
with security built in.
And it's always top of mind
during all of our feature
development processes.
So just to highlight a
few of these features.
Chrome now offers the
ability to generate
safe and easy to use passwords.
So these are passwords that
you don't have to remember,
and you don't
really need to know,
but they're accessible
at any time.
Chrome visually reassures
users that we're
protecting them at the Omnibox
at the top of the screen.
And as I'll talk about in a
minute more on safe browsing
we'll warn users when they
visit malicious sites.
We do research to make
sure these warnings are
easy to understand and not scary
and complicated to end users.
If Chrome detects that
a user's settings have
been tampered with by malware,
we'll reset those settings
automatically.
No tickets to helpdesk.
No other trouble
ticket is needed.
So you always have full control
over the browser experience.
We also offer new features such
as ephemeral profiles, which
allows users to have the full
Chrome signed and experience,
extensions, customizations,
all of those things
can be used as a normal
user, but that profile
can automatically be wiped
when they close out Chrome.
So we're seeing
a lot of interest
in this new environment
such as retail,
hotels where their shared PCs
were that's a common scenario.
You can also set a passphrase
for syncing your data
with Chrome to offer end to
end encryption of that data.
Chrome's PDF reader
also leads industry
in the protection of
untrustworthy PDFs.
So it's very, very
secure way to view PDFs.
So earlier I mentioned
how Chrome updates are
a critical piece of our
story and the browser
has to be updated to be secure.
So here's what we're showing---
so in this example here
we're showing the comparison
of speed updates from Safari
and Chrome.
So as you can see
here, this data
is from clicky.com, which
is a web analytics company.
The shape of the
graph can show over
a period of months
for old versions
to get updated and die off.
And you can see
Safari 8 from 2014
actually is still kicking along.
So this is very consistent with
browsers with annual release
cycles and other browsers that
don't have automatic update
features.
And when you compare
this to Chrome,
you can see the
beauty of auto update.
Old versions disappear
very quickly.
And so does access to those
known vulnerabilities.
We have major releases
every six weeks,
and security updates
can be deployed
as needed whenever
there's a security
vulnerability discovered.
By allowing Chrome
to auto update,
you won't need to wait until
Tuesday for security updates
to be deployed.
Google can deploy those
updates at Google scale.
So we can reach hundreds
of millions of users
around the world in
a matter of hours.
So another security
feature I want to highlight
is Safe Browsing.
Safe Browsing will show
users a warning message
before they visit a dangerous
site or download a harmful app.
Our scanning infrastructure also
protects the Chrome Web Store
from potentially
harmful extensions.
This is the same technology
that we use in the Play Store.
Our technology
protects your company
from a range of malware,
phishing and social engineering
attacks that might try to steal
passwords or infect machines.
If an employee encounters
websites suspected
of being deceptive or dangerous
while browsing the web,
they'll be shown
a warning message.
We'll also show warning
messages on dangerous downloads,
like malware that could
inject ads or again jeopardize
your corporate network.
How many of you have seen
this warning message at home?
OK, just a few.
So OK good, so you're not
visiting sites with malware.
So discovering these
vulnerabilities
are very important to Google.
And we've implemented
technologies
such as fuzzing and
cluster fuzz, which
run thousands of virtual
instances of Chrome
running hundreds of millions
of automated tests every day.
We use this data to analyze
crashes and identify
regressions quickly.
Long before any of these
changes reach the stable channel
of Chrome.
And we know we
can't do this alone.
So we created the Chrome Reward
Program in January of 2010
to help reward the security
researchers and individuals who
invest their time and
energy into helping
us make Chrome more safe.
So we've paid out
more than $9 million
since this program existed
and more than a third of that
was paid out last year.
So more folks have been getting
involved in the near term.
I'm going to mention
a new feature
that we're working on related
to security plan for later
this year.
So we're going to be
adding, even more,
controls for Enterprise Admins.
Things such as location,
determine security level
of the client, as well
as user restrictions
will allow you to both expand
access to your corporate web
applications and at the
same time offer the controls
you need to ensure the
experience is secure end
to end.
So, for example, Chrome
support of security keys
from an administrator
perspective
can specify that their
employees and users
have to be strongly
authenticated
to access a web application.
From a device
management perspective,
you'll be able to
monitor client-side state
and configuration on
across all major platforms.
So this enables the
state of the device
to be monitored by
the infrastructure
so that the state
can be considered
when making an access decision.
The management
capability will integrate
with existing device
management systems you already
have running.
And including system checks
such as if the client has
current anti-virus software
or if the disk is encrypted.
Things along those
lines will be reported,
and a decision will be
made as to allowing access.
These are some of the
examples of the concerns
from our customers.
Talk a little bit about
speed and power improvements.
So Chrome was built to
be fast in every way.
We monitor every aspect of speed
regarding startup time, page
load time, video
rendering of graphics,
complex scripts, Javascript's
and business web applications.
And we also work very
closely with our partners
to maintain top
performance with each
of their software releases.
And of course, as you can
see with the Octane scores
this is a benchmark
of Javascript's speed.
There's been
significant improvements
in over the last
couple of years.
So Chrome is stable because it
was built using multiprocessing
architecture which allocates
each task and every tab
running as a separate process.
So while we constantly update
Chrome with new improvements,
we can quickly
solve any problems
that might cause the
browser to crash.
So I'm sure if you've been
using Chrome for a long period
of time you may have seen a tab
crash but the entire instance
won't.
So again from a security
perspective processes are
isolated, and they cannot talk
across tabs with each other.
So regarding power, over
the past several releases
we've made large improvements
to power consumption on Chrome,
and we now have a large team
dedicated to power reduction.
So this is just a small
example of the change
we made on mobile
devices where we can now
refresh only a small
part of a tile as opposed
to the whole screen.
So this may seem like
a very minor change,
but this is the type
of ongoing effort
to reduce power and
energy consumption
for battery powered devices.
So I mentioned the tile
redraw, but there are also
countless other
efforts across dozens
of components to reduce power
consumption across the board.
So this is showing
the progress we're
making towards reducing
power usage in Chrome.
And with each release, there has
been significant improvements
as you can see here.
So I'll give a quick
update on media as well.
We've also made
large improvements
on bandwidth usage.
So we know that companies
use media in many ways.
Everything ranging from
videoconferencing to now
news and media and social
media which are now
increasingly video based.
Everything even internal
communications such as training
videos, company updates
are now shifting
to be streaming video to
enable access for employees
across multiple locations.
Chrome has extensive
support for WebRTC which
is used for video conferencing.
And we are now working hard
to improve video codecs
to decrease bandwidth
usage while maintaining
the same video quality.
While not allowed to share
the exact YouTube stats,
to give you a sense of the scale
of video watch time and Chrome
it's truly staggering.
There are thousands
of years of video
played in Chrome every day.
So what else can we do
to improve this area?
Chrome supports the latest
video codecs including VP9
to improve quality
and reduce bandwidth.
So as you can see here,
the image on the left
is clear and uses
30% less bandwidth
than H264 which is on the right.
Chrome also supports
DRM which allows
you to protect your
sensitive corporate videos.
The support is deployed through
a component called Widevine
which is available
across Mac, Windows,
Linux Android and Chrome OS.
We also support--
we now allow users
to download secure content
and offline video playback
is supported as well.
When you playback
videos, Chrome can also
cast that to larger
screens or other devices
for easier viewing.
So as I mentioned, VP9
will say more than 30%
of video bandwidth
at the same quality.
This can result in some 30%
savings on a video encoded
at a one megabit bit
rate for 1,000 employees
would equate to more than a gig
of mobile data savings per day.
And obviously, one megabit
video they rate is very low.
So it can obviously add up.
In addition to video,
Chrome has support for WebP
which is a higher image quality
than JPEG of the same file
size.
So for companies with large
internal image databases,
this also can improve visual
quality and save on storage.
So I'm going to talk a little
bit about some of the Chrome
enterprise management features.
So today there are a couple
hundred management features
that allow you to control the
Chrome experience end to end.
Everything from
setting a home page
to force deploying extensions
to configuring and proxy servers
all of these things
can be deployed
within your existing Active
Directory infrastructure
or through our
cloud-based console.
It's the same Chrome browser
that uses are familiar with,
but now IT can customize it
to meet your company's needs.
We are also now offering a 24/7
enterprise support offering
should you need to
troubleshoot or escalate
any issues with our team.
Now we know very well that
moving to the open web
is not going to
happen overnight.
And those legacy applications
from 10 and 15 years ago that
used Silverlight and Active-X
are not going anywhere
in the near future.
We know that you rely
on those apps every day.
And we want to make it
as easy and seamless as
possible through to for
your users to access those
applications.
So we've built a tool called
Legacy Browser Support.
And this will allow Admins to
configure Chrome as the default
browser and define a number of
sites it should still be opened
with an alternative browser.
When the user is done with the
Legacy browser and the Legacy
property, it will be seamlessly
switched back to Chrome
to resume where they left off.
No training or change
management needed.
So while Chrome's auto update
feature enables your company
to be on the safest
fastest version of Chrome,
we know that many companies
also want flexibility
when making these types
of changes and upgrades.
So you can choose to
leave auto update on
to get those security fixes.
Or you can also
disable auto updates
and manage the timing of
updates on your own schedule
based on your
organization's needs.
For example, you may only
want to allow updates
at certain times
or weekends, or you
want to deploy after
you've had more
time to test the new release.
And those are all
fully supported
through group policy
that can be configured
across all platforms.
So Chrome connects to Google
for tools that require access
to our cloud.
For example, predictive
search or translate features
will need to connect to Google.
You will always have control
to turn off these features
and control what data
is shared with Google.
Again all configurable
by policy.
So as you run more and more
of your business on the web,
you can use policies to define
what absence extensions get
published to your employees.
In an upcoming
release of Chrome,
we're going to be offering
Admins, even more, control
over applications and extensions
by allowing them to restrict
which extensions can be
deployed based on the permission
the app or extension declarers.
For example, today it's very
common for administrators
to control applications
through a list or block list.
With this new feature
instead of having
to kind of curate what
applications are allowed
or blacklist applications that
you discover after the fact,
you'll be able to
restrict every extension,
for example, that
needs to access
the webcam or the microphone.
And then not have to
get into reviewing
each extension manually.
This also will include future
updates for extensions.
So if you have a note taking
extension deployed today
and in the future it for some
reason needs a microphone,
that would automatically
be disabled
as you would have to monitor
every single update of Chrome
extensions.
So Chrome is the
only browser that
is cross-platform
and can be managed
from a single
cloud-based console.
And we believe the browser
should be stateless
and that management should
be easy no matter what
device the user picks up.
So we offer Chrome enterprise
support due to customer demand.
So we understand that it's
a blocker for many companies
to move to Chrome if they're
not able to get enterprise level
support directly from Google.
So we began offering
this last year.
And it's worth noting that
this is targeted specifically
for non-G Suite customers.
If you already are
a G Suite customer
this services included.
And this is more targeted for
larger enterprises typically
more than 1,000 users or more.
So that concludes my remarks.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]